The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Hi, I'm Jocelyn, and
today we're going to go
over Fall 2009 Exam 2,
Problem number 5.
As always, we're going to read
the problem first. Which
compound do you expect to have
the higher boiling point: HF
or ammonia?
Justify your choice with an
explanation, using narrative
or cartoons or both that makes
reference to the operative
chemical bonding.
So first, we are trying to
figure out which has a greater
temperature of vaporization,
or boiling point; and we're
looking at HF and ammonia.
Now when we're talking about
boiling points, we're talking
about breaking a certain type of
bond, and that type of bond
is intermolecular bonds.
We're not going to be breaking
the actual molecular bonds
bonding hydrogen to fluorine
or nitrogen, we're breaking
the bonds in between molecules
of HF or ammonia, and so what
types of bond do we
have to look at?
And Professor Sadoway, in class,
went over a couple of
different types of
intermolecular bonds.
And I'm going to write
them down in order
of increasing strengths.
So the weakest intermolecular
bonds we
have are Van der Waals.
The next is induced
dipole-dipole.
Next we have dipole-dipole, and
finally a special type of
dipole-dipole is the
hydrogen-bond, which is the
strongest. So here we're
increasing strength.
Van der Waals is an induced
dipole-dipole.
That means that although your
atom or molecule does not have
a net dipole, the electrons can
shift, and at some point
will cause a difference in
polarity between different
sides of the molecule.
Induced dipole-dipole is
two different molecules
interacting: one that has no net
dipole and one that does.
Dipole-dipole: pretty
self-explanatory.
You have two molecules that
have dipoles, and they are
interacting.
And then hydrogen-bond is when
you have hydrogen bonded with
x, where x is nitrogen,
oxygen, and fluorine.
We call that a hydrogen-bond,
because these are really,
really strong dipole-dipole
interactions and cause much
different behaviors in
molecules, and so we, kind of,
separate it out at the subset.
So now that we've reviewed
intermolecular bonds, let's go
back to the problem.
So we were asked to figure out
the difference, or which one
has a higher vapor pressure, or
temperature of boiling, so
that's a relative thing.
And as we now know that we need
to look at intermolecular
bonds, a good place to start is
with the Lewis structure,
because that will tell us if
we have dipoles or not, and
then we can see what the
strongest intermolecular bond
is that we need to break to
boil these molecules.
So starting with HF, we have
hydrogen bonded to fluorine.
We know that fluorine has a much
higher electronegativity
than hydrogen, so we're going
to have a net dipole.
Well, we have a polarized
bond and a net
dipole towards fluorine.
This causes there to be a
partial positive charge on the
hydrogen and a partial negative
charge on the fluorine.
So what is our strongest
intermolecular bond that we
have for HF?
Going back to our list of bonds,
we see that we have a
dipole, so we might first think
about dipole-dipole.
However, we need to remember
about hydrogen bonds, and here
in HF, we have hydrogen bonded
to fluorine, and so that would
be our strongest interaction.
So let's write that down
to keep track.
Now for ammonia, we have
nitrogen bonded to three
hydrogens, and again we
have a difference in
electronegativity, and so each
of these bonds is polar.
And because of the asymmetric
geometry, we will have a net
dipole, and each of these
have a partially --
sorry, the hydrogens have a
partially positive charge,
right, because they are less
electronegative, and the
nitrogen has a partial
negative charge.
So, which is our highest or
strongest intermolecular bond
that we have here.
Again, we have a net dipole, and
so we have dipole-dipole
interactions, but because
hydrogen is bonded to one of
the special three atoms, we
have hydrogen bonding, and
that is the strongest. So, that
is what we care about.
So now, we're, kind of, at a
roadblock here; both have
hydrogen bonding, which is the
strongest intermolecular bond.
So how do we decide which one
is actually going to be
stronger than the other, and
therefore, have the higher
boiling point.
Well even though they're both
hydrogen bonds, they will have
difference in strength, and
that's going to depend on the
partial positive and partial
negative charges, because all
of these interactions are due
to coulombic attraction.
In fluorine, we know that
fluorine is the most
electronegative element and has
a higher electronegativity
than nitrogen, so just to keep
track of our thought process
here: this will cause the
partial positive on hydrogen
to be larger in the HF than in
the ammonia, and so from this
we can say that the hydrogen
bonding in HF will be stronger
than the hydrogen bonding in
ammonia, and therefore, the t
evaporation of HF will be
greater than the t--
the boiling point of ammonia.
So now we're going to
move on to Part B.